merci alain on va suivre maintenant
votre reportage on le voit bien depuis
plusieurs mois déjà c'est comme si
barack obama avait un rendez vous avec
l'histoire de son pays un destin qu'il a
écrit au fil du temps et que vous nous
rappeler ce soir c'est le grand format
de ce dimanche le 4 novembre le monde
entier l'amérique quasi unanime salue
l'élection du premier président noir des
etats unis
mais la vérité objectifs de la couleur
de peau correspond elle à la vérité
subjective vécue par l'intéressé en fait
barack obama s'est longtemps sentie
blanc son père kenyan quitte femme et
enfant alors qu'il est bébé il est donc
élevé par des blancs sa mère et sa grand
mère surtout en partie élevé mais en
même temps elle avoue avoir peur
lorsqu'elle croise un noir dans la rue
oui il ya un tantinet raciste la grand
mère mais qu importe barak qui se fait
appeler perry ne sais pas ce que racine
sy fy il a vécu en indonésie avec le
second mari de sa mère un indonésien
il a une soeur aurasienne et hawaii où
il est au lycée est une mosaïque de race
seulement ce pays si vous avez
l'apparence d'un noir on vous traitera
comme au noir en arrivant en californie
dans cette université de los angeles
c'est donc le choc pour ses nouveaux
camarades baril n'est rien d'autre que
barack un noir un [ __ ] pour un peu le
jeune étudiant se révoltent se droguent
tourne mal et se réfugie finalement dans
le travail en deux ans j'ai vécu deux
mois je ne faisais calais au cours lire
écrire réfléchir je ne sortais jamais et
ça paye cette vie de moine colombia abad
les plus grandes universités en même
temps barack fait la paix avec lui même
puisqu'on le voit comme noir et bien il
va se consacrer à sa communauté dans les
quartiers sud de chicago et à michel sa
femme 100% afro américaines elles dont
il aura deux enfants deux adorables
petites filles
entre temps il aura fait un pèlerinage
au kenya histoire de faire aussi une
paix posthume avec son père décédé dans
un accident de voiture ce père qu'il
n'aura connu finalement qu'un mois
dix ans un père dont le souvenir le
hante au point de lui avoir consacré le
titre de son autobiographie on est
essentielle
ce que j'ai retenu de lui c'est une
absence je me suis rendu compte lorsque
je suis devenu père moi même qui ont des
choses les plus importantes que je
pouvais donner c'est une présence enfin
bien dans ses baskets
il irradie un charisme fou une
intelligence brillante un sens de
l'organisation in et une autorité
naturelle et revers de la médaille une
très haute idée de lui-même à l'antenne
je ne sens pas avoir de défaut qui
puisse m'empêcher de fonctionner comme
présidente
même si comme tout le monde je dois
m'améliorer
son ascension est fulgurante 2005 il
entre au sénat des etats-unis 2007 il
annonce sa candidature à la
maison-blanche 2008
il bouscule non sans mal hillary clinton
et décroche la nomination d box
4 novembre il est élu triomphalement
grâce où en dépit de sa couleur de peau
le problème finalement n'était pas là il
était avant tout le meilleur
le seul dans ces temps troublés a donné
l'essentiel l'espoir et puis une
dernière image celle d'un portrait
officiel preuve s'il en fallait une
nouvelle fois qu'une page se tourne aux
états unis c'est le portrait officiel
est plutôt moderne du futur président
américain barack obama qui était
dévoilée aujourd'hui